efectivamente bueno un analista en la
radio france abajo decía no sé cómo le
creen a boris johnson porque él no
cumple con los tratados que ha firmado
en este caso hablamos del tratado del
precise recordemos que las aguas del
reino unido son muy ricas y era de allí
de adónde sacaban principalmente los
productos todos los pescadores de la
unión europea por lo tanto cuando hubo
la salida del reino unido se logró ese
acuerdo para que londres permitiera a
los pescadores europeos seguir pescando
pero para eso tenía que darle unas
licencias y hay un retraso especialmente
con los pescadores franceses francia
dice que le faltan todavía 150 licencias
londres dice que ya casi ha entregado el
98 por ciento lo cierto es que son
requisitos diferentes lo que aplica a
parís que lo que aplica a londres lo que
hay que demostrar es que uno pescaba en
las aguas británicas antes del break
sheet lo que pasa es que hay varios
barcos una cuarentena de barcos
franceses que son nuevos el reino unido
dice que no les va a licencia porque son
barcos más potentes que podrían pescar
más entonces como una medida de presión
estos pescadores que dicen que han
perdido ya mucho dinero que están
perdiendo entre un 30 y un 50 por ciento
de sus ganancias hoy han pasado a la
acción han bloqueado tres puertos o
franceses el de sant valor el de
ouistreham y el de cale y en estos
momentos están bloqueando justamente el
túnel bajo la mancha osea que en la
actualidad hoy se encuentra en el norte
de francia raúl veremos la reacción al
de el reino unido y también del lado
francés en todo caso la presión va para
el primer ministro británico pero
también para el presidente manuel macrón
raúl